no worse always pay it forward that's my
motto
you know and cuz that any given moment
one of us could need a helping hand
like now YouTube total strangers you
know we're short on cash and then
someone just steps out of the blue and
helps out I don't we ran away am i right
okay
have we met no no I'm a complete and
total stranger right okay all right
Oregon Trail shout-out how about the
ending of that episode so the episode
itself was obviously a love letter to
classic 90s flash TV series a lot of the
references they made were dedicated to
that but also to the idea of family
trickster family versus flash family so
that gives you a better idea for what
was going on at the end of the episode
of jitters so I'll try to explain
everything but there was some stuff from
behind the scenes that posted that I'll
try to avoid posting till later this
week just because it is a little bit
spoilery so I'll try to stick to what we
know from this episode general spoilers
for episode 11 if you haven't seen it
yet so top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs
as we go along starting with number 10
everybody's dealing with Barry being in
prison first you get the shot of Barry
trying to clean up the prison riot
without using his powers and a really
obvious way just giving you an idea for
how he's going to serve his time so he
will be using his powers but only in
really extreme situations when he's
trying to save people's lives or voyages
all-out prison war which was what was
going on at the beginning of the episode
but the idea is is that he's gonna have
to serve his time the only way he's
gonna get out is if they can prove to
the judge that there was something funky
going on so like we've talked about
before there are a lot of lines of
dialogue that are essentially teeing up
things that they'll pay off later and
one of those things was is that Joe and
Cecile will have a meeting with the
judge later that might happen in a later
episode it might happen next week some
of the things they set up they pay off
right away but some stuff they just see
for way off down the road like at the
very end of the episode when the very
clearly speedster girl from the future
is riding down those Flash symbols that
Barry was riding when he came out at the
Speed Force number 9 another marvel
spiderman reference a whole bunch of
Marvel references this year in addition
to Caitlin being like the Hulk we
your friendly neighborhood elongated
spider-man so this is basically the
episode that gives him the comic-book
name in a version of his comic book
costume they changed it just a little
bit I think because his comic book
costume looks so close to the Flash's
red costume if they want to
differentiate them a little bit so it's
a little closer to the silver comic book
costume which is from the classic comics
but you you understand how they like
modernize certain thing like when prank
came back this is what her classic 90s
costume looked like just you know
hilarious looking spandex so obviously
everybody gets an update you can
definitely tell they went above and
beyond to show you how his powers work
what his weaknesses are just to give you
an idea that there are things that can
hurt him he's not completely
indestructible even though they make all
kinds of references to kryptonite
xenomorph blood it's hilarious how much
of a movie fan that Harrison wells from
earth-2 is and the fact that they have
the bubble gum the Cisco loves so much
that went out 20 years ago on our earth
which is really more of a metaphor for
the original series which I'll explain
in a second so a lot of the jokes about
things that died out 20 years ago like
the toy stores that's a reference for
the original series going off the air 20
plus years ago but number 7 welcome back
Axl Walker trickster so remember back
during season 1 we learned that Mark
Hamill's James Jessie trickster was the
original version of the character from
the 90s series who had just been rotting
in prison ever since the trial of the
trickster which actually wound up being
the series finale because they cancelled
the show after that but that was also
the episode that introduced the prank
character and because we're doing the
trial of the flash the trial of the
trickster there's just so many Easter
eggs so it's just ripe for the plucking
that they do an episode like this right
after they do the trial of the flash
episode so the whole idea is is that
after that he goes to prison rots then
gets out during season one of the flash
is broke out by the axle Walker
trickster then does the whole Star Wars
Darth Vader I am your father
but up to that point we really don't
hear from his mother who is now
officially confirmed to be the prank
character who was sort of the Harley
Quinn - James Jesse's trickster but I
just did a video sort of explaining her
history about how she predates the
Harley Quinn character so she was like
Harley Quinn before there was a Harley
Quinn number 6 though this is actually
really important for the future so if
you didn't see mark
Hamill was tweeting about the episode
he's been busy with Star Wars press
because the last Jedi obviously he's
getting ready to go back and do episode
9 really soon - so yes 100% I think that
he'll come back for another episode but
because of the way prank was talking
about him he doesn't care about our
family Axl he broke out of prison a year
ago and he hasn't been seen since he
hasn't contacted us or tried to come
back he's out in the wild somewhere so
he could always come back for a Luke vs.
Vader trickster family episode so if you
haven't watched the original series
there's this funny story that Mark
Hamill tells about how basically his
character James jesse on the original
series treated prank like complete crap
like he walked all over her and she was
completely devoted to him so when prank
is talking about how Axl's father does
not care about them I'm the one that
raised you while your father was out
getting thrown in prison all the time
trying to commit crime this sort of an
inside joke about how much of a dirtbag
the James Jesse character was originally
like Joker mistreats Harley Quinn but it
was way worse on that 90s flash TV
series so they're just teeing up the
idea that James Jesse will be a villain
for Axl and in the comics if you guys
didn't know Jeff John's actually wrote
this cool battle that the two versions
of the trickster had in the comics that
I think that they could do but in the
comics they're not related the TV show
set that up with the Darth Vader reveals
during season 1 but still in the comics
all it is is Axl just steals all of
James Jesse's tricks his costumes and
takes the name so they become enemies
but eventually Axl does finally become
the official version of the trickster so
I think we'll slowly see that happen on
the TV show when Mark Hamill is
available for another episode but like I
said when they go back to that abandoned
toy factory because she's like this
chemist she's the heir to the fortune of
this toy company gadzooks cisco's like
no you don't have the gum Harrison wells
is like yes we do we still have the gum
on earth - they're sort of making the
joke that the original flash TV series
which went out 20-plus years ago like
the gum did on the TV show is still
running so it's just a fun way of saying
that on earth - the classic flash TV
series never got cancelled but number
five meet Goldberg just another wrestler
on the TV show we're gonna have to have
some sort of wrestler team-up maybe for
a Fight Club 3.0 or 4.0 at some point he
is a comic book
character on the TV show he tells Barry
that his real name is Dave but in the
comics his real name is doofus P ratchet
so they're just using the name and
making a couple of jokes about him being
this giant dumb strong person but if it
wasn't clear what his relationship with
Barry's father was when he was back in
prison preceding season one is that he
basically had some sort of condition
that needed to be operated on no one
would do it but Barry's father because
he was a surgeon agreed to do it and
saved his life
so now Barry's officially made a new
friend he's gonna help protect him even
though Barry technically doesn't need
help being protected because he's using
his super speed the takedown in that
fight was pretty hilarious too so he's
using his powers but in really subtle
ways the really funny thing though he
has this line of dialogue where he says
like father like son after the fights
over because Barry took down those
criminals so one is a bit of a joke that
Barry's father was a good fighter
because he's a big guy John Wesley Shipp
is a pretty big guy but also like father
like son
isn't Grant Gustin is playing the flash
Barry Allen whose father was also Barry
Allen on the classic TV series so it's
sort of another three levels deep Easter
egg and I'm not a hundred percent but I
do think that a lot of elongated man's
one-liners in his dialogue like when he
had really funny phrases were taken from
the classic TV series like they just
lifted dialogue right out of that number
four elongated man versus trickster
round one basically him eating all those
weapons then almost getting melted like
the Wicked Witch of the West is just a
way of showing you that he will have a
weakness that will probably come back
around later this season he's mostly
indestructible against kinetic damage
and blast damage so like he can eat
bombs he can take bullets throwing stars
basically anything you could throw at
him but we get our big dark night rises
Easter Egg when Barry talks about his
time to rise inmate three five six two
definitely feels like an easter egg but
I couldn't find any reference to any
particular comic book or anything like
that but then they roll back into action
I love that Caitlin's Hulk out phrase is
Alexey LaRoche her childhood bully so
all they had to do is just say that and
instantly she hooks out but I absolutely
love when Irish throws him that tiny
little case and he opens it up Pulp
Fiction style like it's the briefcase
from Pulp Fiction only miniaturised it's
basically his suit that he's looking at
when he says groovy he's quoting Bruce
Campbell from Evil Dead so sick movie
reference but number three obviously
family trickster versus team flash I
love the way they have this set up to
they basically do the same thing during
the original flash 90s series so they
were trying to recreate a moment like
that where you have team flash strapped
into this gear but on the original
series it was them trying to scramble
Flash's brain so that he would turn evil
and start helping the trickster out on
this series it was all about melting
them with acid but if you don't remember
Bebo there were a whole bunch of Bebo
Easter eggs for legends of tomorrow
because it was the MacGuffin of an
episode where it basically got sent back
in time and started to be worshipped as
a God of War so if you weren't sure what
was going on with Bebo that was just a
running plot gag that they carried over
from legends of tomorrow but number two
elongated man of course gets his comic
book name I was surprised that he gave
it to himself in the way that they spin
the newspaper is just like the 90s flash
TV series during that press conference
they actually played the classic
trickster music from the end of the
trial of the trickster episode in the
90s series so they ended both of those
episodes in relatively the same way with
you know very comedic Spade like they
tilted the camera into kind of a Dutch
angle but obviously number one we have
to freak out about Dawn Allen or you
know we could call her future speedster
but it does feel like it's dawn Allen
picking up the bill at jitters and
implying that she is from the future
like Oregon Trail it's a classic but
it's really not that much of a classic
because it's from the 80s so they want
to be a little ambiguous about it but
here's the thing she's riding the same
speed for symbols that Barry was riding
when he came out of the Speed Force but
if you're not absolutely convinced that
she belongs to Barry and iris like one
she sort of looks like she's mixed race
she looks like she could be the daughter
of someone who was an african-american
female in a white male but also she
talks the same way that Barry talks the
first time he appeared on arrow that
really quick excitedness about his
speech she has a really technical mind
like Barry has she's talking about all
these big science concepts and this
really excited way like even cisco isn't
talking that fast and he's one of the
smartest people on team flash like he's
like okay that's great nice shirt loved
Oregon Trail but here's the thing a lot
of people are wondering if that means
that she might be a version of Bart
Allen instead of being Don West because
Bart Allen is always portrayed as being
this
really excitable member of the flash
family but he's Barry's grandson not his
daughter
but a lot of that gets into why iris
might potentially get powers briefly
later this season in the Easter Egg is
in the fact that Cecile's pregnancy is
going to cause her to get powers
temporarily so with iris temporarily
gets powers it might be because she's
pregnant and because we met the wedding
caterer
total stranger never met this person
before that she is Barry and irises
daughter dawn Allen so remember they did
have the tornado twins so there's a boy
dawn Allen who knows how they're gonna
handle that but I think it all just goes
back to we're gonna need more diapers
reveal at the end of the season I don't
think that we're gonna find out to
really like the last couple of episodes
what's really going on but I think we
all have a pretty good idea and I will
do a separate video just piecing all
this information together in a really
linear easier to understand way like
this is what they're applying this is
what they're setting up this is who this
person actually is but if there were any
other Easter eggs you spot in the
episode that I didn't mention in the
video just write them in the comments
below there is a new route of that blast
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber and share
the video using those YouTube tools on
the watch page there and I'll say
congratulations to the winner from my
last video from a little while ago
Christian Lucho please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post new
flash tomorrow but I will also post my
Black Lightning episode to video and we
might get a Star Wars Han Solo trailer
this week so big stuff happening this
week big reveals click here to learn a
little bit more about the history of the
trickster and iris West potentially
being a speedster briefly this season
and click here for that brand new Black
Panther trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight